as weird as this looks I'd love to give
this a go
we travel to a Cockeysville France to
meet the mind behind this maverick
masterpiece
diddly oprima el nido and said yo yo
volley baton diesel edema Tilly's wazoo
if we look at cafe apparently or primo
city list well the gomangani job
jean-pierre took 20 years to develop as
machine but what's it like to actually
fly last on session to vote on a or
Emily cage receiver society bar wow so
much so so community fantastic Tomas how
does this machine fly an arm power alone
the first challenge jean-pierre had to
overcome when building a human powered
flying machine is how to keep it in the
air so instead of using an engine with
wings or rotors he decided to use
buoyancy jean-pierre knows that helium
atoms are smaller and lighter than the
atoms in normal air so a balloon filled
with helium will be about seven times
lighter than a balloon filled with the
same volume of n provided that that
helium plus the rider plus all the
balloon and support structure weigh less
than the air that the whole thing
displaces it becomes buoyant Jean
Pierre's gone one step further and found
a condition called neutral buoyancy
that's where the upward force of the
helium in the balloon perfectly balances
the downward force of gravity therefore
the craft remains at the same height
unless the pilot flies it up or down
amid cube helium and kilo Ora make you
cake you know she suicide Sankyo
minimums Vasant Ahmed cube video
jean-pierre has crafted these large
wings which attach to the pilots arms he
had to make the wings light enough so
that they could be held by the pilot but
also so they wouldn't add too much
weight to the overall craft so he made
the wings out of a lightweight canvas
stretched over a carbon fiber frame
Ashutosh over here Yasha [ __ ] bull and
they all prim agree family dynamics
additional common or form we could scoff
at the idea of a personalized blimp but
look how easy is getting about this
could be the future
you